he is on Sunday night football's a
pregame postgame halftime football night
in America's Rodney Harrison from NBC
Sports joining us here how are you
Rodney
Rich Eisen what's up buddy how are you
it's been a long time since we have
spoken always great to chat with you
how's your family everybody good happy
healthy say it's all good you know what
we're happy and healthy but the kids are
you know they're 11 they're 9 they're 6
they're being remote schooled they
haven't seen their friends they wonder
when the next time they're gonna see
their friends it's it's it ain't easy
it's tough to explain to them what's
going on to be very honest with you yeah
you know and we try to explain the same
thing with our kids you got to be
patient humble and then just um it's
building of character and everybody's
going through it is not just you so hang
in there I know that's what we're trying
to all do but I appreciate you taking
the time here and let's jump in let's
jump in with both feet
Rodney Harrison right here on the Rich
Eisen show the NFL conversation is dak
Prescott worth the money that we're
hearing being thrown about right now
Leeza starting quarterback and I think
he's a top 10 quarterback in this league
and in most situations you would have a
team that would be willing to pay him I
don't know if it's you know he's upset
about the years or the money but it's a
heck of a lot of money and one thing
about dak you know and he's expressed as
before you're just not going to get him
to sign just anything I think it has to
be right form I think he he understands
his value and as a player regardless of
what the owners say you always have to
understand and respect your own value
because if you don't nobody else will so
is that a yes I'm sorry Richard yes yes
definitely I think he deserves the money
I mean it started smacking National
Football League and they can win a Super
Bowl with that Prescott despite you know
I mean a lot of people's objections I
believe that dak is gonna continue to
get better he's gonna be continue to be
one of the top quarterbacks in this
league and with some added pieces around
them I think he's gonna excel even more
I agree with you Rodney however just you
know I'm not really a devil's advocate
guy but the other side of this
conversation does have a valid argument
in the fact that somebody who is paid as
much as he's asking to be paid and is
going to get paid even if it's just
obviously at the franchise tag rate
should be able to shoulder the season
that had occurred last year he should be
able to take this team that went eight
and eight and was so patently
disappointing putting it on his back and
shoulders and make it a ten and six team
and take him to the playoffs that's that
a transformational athlete that's
getting paid that much that's they are
you do that rich I think I believe that
he can do that and you know them going
and you know accomplishing what they
accomplish it the limited success that
they had last year wasn't just based off
of that Prescott I mean it's an entire
team but if you're asking me in the next
four to five years if this guy is
capable of really taking them far and
we've seen a team you know we've seen
teams that didn't really look great and
you know had you know people thought
they were overrated and then all of a
sudden you know you know this team gets
hot and they take off I just believe
that I believe in that Prescott because
I believe in the person I believe in his
work ethic the way it conducts himself
the way he deals with his teammates how
highly they speak of him how hard you
know how hard he works his work ethic I
just believe in that I just believe that
every year you know you can't improve as
a quarterback as a player and I think he
will continue to do that best team in
the NFC South is which Wow best team in
the NFC South I would say the Saints at
this point even with with with Brady
being there I just think that with Brady
being there yeah all the virtual
learning and all the hope that he brings
but there's still something about
chemistry there's still something about
being able to be around your teammates
being able to practice and just having
that camaraderie but I think it's the
Saints just with Drew Brees and Sean
Payton that system is in play and I
think that defense is going to continue
to get better
why is Cam Newton jobless right now do
you think
because nobody knows I'm rich I mean
nobody knows what's going on with kam as
far as you know can you depend on him is
with his health you know what's his
mental and at this point in time you
can't invest a lot of money because he's
been so beat up I think the best thing
for him to do is go and go in the
situation maybe go become a backup
quarterback learn get healthy and then
if he gets his opportunity go out there
and shine but I don't think he's gonna
be a star quarterback this year that's
crazy if I was the Chargers out I mean
if you're gonna Yolo it for Tom Brady
and you're gonna brainer you know what I
mean like again III don't you know if
Brady is worth it because you feel you
can win now and you need Fannie's in the
new seats now then why isn't cama fit
because he's got more runway he's got
potentially much longer to go there he
definitely puts Fannie's in the seats
but I looked at the Patriots I really
wanted to patron I know I you know a lot
of people out there scented Patriots but
I thought it would be a great situation
where he could have came in at a reduced
salary he could have came in and really
learned a lot about just technique and
and just the intricacies of you know
just being on a really great football
team with great guidance as far as a
offensive coordinator I thought that
would have been a really really ideal
situation for him he could have came and
competed could they help the young guy a
young guy could have helped to push him
I thought it would have been a perfect
situation I'm just a little disappointed
that on the Patriots weren't a little
bit more aggressive you know just
recruiting Cameron and and he knows he
wasn't gonna make 20-something million
dollars this year and it could have
definitely been at a reduced rate he's
made so much money in his career but if
anybody knows Belichick Ronnie Harrison
it would be you and the whole sense is
that Belichick does not like cams which
one would say ball security issues on
occasion or his inaccuracies that he
would be the one guy that would
absolutely drive Belichick crazy and
that has nothing to do with at all about
the professionalism the whole
conversation of cam not being a
professional or professional enough is
insane
that it would be oil and water what
would you say we're going in here so
much receipt
come off the top all these players that
I've spoken to I meet around Ali they
have so much respect they ask me
questions about Bella checking his way
and how we had success and things like
that I don't think can would have came
in and been a problem Cam's a good guy
yeah at times he acts a little immature
and I think he's learned from that
immaturity but there's no reason what a
guy like can Newton the type of fire and
the type of arm just passionate he
brings he's a good he's a good person
yet he made some mistakes with some
interviews and the way he's handled some
situations but he's a good guy he's
still a great football player and I just
do now but wish him the best words
because I'm it's no reason why he
shouldn't be playing in national
football league Rodney Harrison here in
the Rich Eisen show um do you have
anything for Eli Manning's new Twitter
account I haven't seen anything from you
yet Rodney yeah yeah did you see he's on
Twitter man let me tell you something
about my Twitter account okay I was
active with Twitter I got excited about
it just years ago and then I'd said a
few things on national television and
people just started killing me sausage
you know what every week that I say
something I have thousands of fans
always saying something so I kind of
ignore my Twitter account before you
know it it's been like at least a couple
years before I even tweeted anything out
so I have to get back active on my
Twitter yeah I can't let people distract
me you know Ronnie you know your brand
is is is about not avoiding contact so I
don't understand why that would be you
know you could pick and choose as to
where you you know place your your
Twitter characters and on whom you can
handle that sort of thing I'm not that
guy that you know I don't I don't want
it to become a job you know I just I'm
just a normal guy you know and and I
don't I don't like a lot of people kind
of like knowing prying in my business
and it's it's different because I'm such
an old-school guy I'm 47 years old and
to openly put pictures and everything of
my life out there just a little bit of
hesitancy so I'm not saying you should
tweet like you're 12 you know I'm saying
you've got things to say you could put
it in 240 characters and you could you
know fire at Eli Manning about being on
Twitter
about you know that is what about Peyton
Manning didn't you just have Peyton my
pain man an enemy just say this I was
watching these guys play I was so
disappointed in their golfing especially
Brady babies my boy he took me to Pine
Valley when I first got to New England
flew me over there we go golfing
beautiful beautiful course it's always
like as tough as gusty to get on yes and
Brady's always talking about how great
of a golfer he is and he stuck in front
of millions and millions of people
he had one good quality shot see now if
you would put that out on Twitter in
real-time just think of all the retweets
you could get Rodney okay but but am I
am I am I put in an out there to get a
reaction
no one's weird to me like I don't I'm
not trying to get attention if I say
something so you're saying I get a
thousand retweets but that's not
important to me
yeah you should stay out of it then I
think problem I'm gonna start yes
probably sometime this weekend my first
tweet might be at you and and you know
what and do it and and on behalf of
because we're on NBC Sports NBC SN right
now on behalf of this show to NBC Sports
and their their staff there I say you're
welcome or I'm sorry one or the other I
might even just make it a personal note
on my phone alarm just everyday wake up
and tweet Rich Eisen Rodney underscore
Harrison thanks to the time rod
appreciated a man is always a pleasure
talking to you take care take care of
the you and your families Rodney
Harrison he only knows one speed good
so again NBC Sports PR you're welcome
cuz you know anybody on a sports network
that tweets that's good we're always
telling everybody tweet just hover with
the thumb over sin that's it just just
hover that's all you need to do hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here